Long Live Palestine Long Live Palestine
we will honor all our martys we will
honor all our Mars all our children Sons
and Daughters all our children Sons and
Daughters we will honor all our Mars we
will honor all our Mars all our children
sons and daughters we are here today to
honor our Martyrs and to honor the
struggle for Liberation that they made
the ultimate sacrifice
for over the past few days the SST
entity has rained and continued to rain
down bombs and missiles on
indiscriminately targeting men women and
children slaughtering entire families
and buildings of families in a single
strike our resistance Fighters are
defying Zionist intelligence as we speak
exposing the cracks in its Ironclad
foundation and dispelling the illusion
of its
invincibility even the backing of all
the world's most powerful imperialist
states cannot suppress our people whose
resistance defies every Colonial tool
weaponized against
us they call us Savages
barbarians terrorists
but we know who the real terrorists
are for every martyr we gain another
Rises to take their place glory to our
Martyrs each and
everyone they have made the ultimate
sacrifice for Liberation May their
memories continue to light the fire of
resistance and guide us on the path to
Liberation and
return
the mobilization is not
unprovoked it is a response to the
brutal blockade that has left over 2
million of our people languishing under
starvation and
Terror it is a response to the Zionist
entity State terrorism and mass bombing
of G that has murdered thousands of our
people